los datos salen de un reporte de estudio
de la universidad de oxford
climatológica y
una
persona que se llama friederike otro que
también ha escrito el reporte
climatológico mundial presente
porque piensan ustedes que bolsonaro
podría ser juzgado por esta corte países
desarrollados o como austria ya
domesticaron sus bosques y en
explotación de recursos entonces en qué
medida se puede exigir a un país en
desarrollo que modere sus recursos
es una pregunta muy difícil claro que sí
la destrucción medioambiental en brasil
la destrucción masiva de la selva
tropical
en primer lugar es afecta a la población
local pero también
tiene un impacto global
el fundador de la iniciativa yo les hice
mal y yo no tenemos ninguna conexión
especial con brasil pero también somos
ciudadanos de este mundo y ambos tenemos
hijos y yo sí tenemos una responsable
para la
responsabilidad por ciento 200.000 años
más por el futuro y quiero decir que no
queremos hacer
colonialismo jurisdiccional con la
denuncia penal pero la destrucción de la
selva tropical
tiene consecuencias globales si tenemos
tenemos hacer algo contra él
bueno y además el rise denuncia que el
gobierno de derecha de bolsonaro buscó
sistemáticamente eliminar mutilar y
vaciar de contenido de las leyes los
organismos e individuos que protegían la
amazonía de manera que cuatro mil
kilómetros de selva se han perdido cada
año desde que asumió en 2019 qué
implicaciones que tendría para bolsonaro
un pronunciamiento de la cpi
no
sabemos que estamos entrando un nuevo
territorio legal con esta denuncia penal
el tribunal penal aún no ha tenido que
decidir sobre un caso de este tipo en el
pasado
pero conseguimos demostrar que el
tribunal puede y tiene competencia para
juzgar estos delitos medioambientales
como crímenes de la en contra de la
humanidad y las consecuencias serían
quizás una
examinación y sería algo muy bueno para
la iniciativa si la fiscalía el tribunal
empieza con examinaciones